hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled best practices in quality control
10 simple recommendations i'm sabrina
lamos of labrutz and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
bio rad laboratories i would like to
invite
everyone to participate by submitting
your questions during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions that we don't answer
during the webinar will be captured
and responded to through a q a list that
will be posted next week in the event
resources box which is located below the
ask a question box
you will also be able to download the
presentation handouts
from this event resources box
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation
please also submit your concerns in the
ask a question box
and we will address your issue as a
reminder this presentation is
educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located on the top right corner of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
now let's get started i now present
today speaker
dr curtis parvin dr parvin's expertise
is in biostatistics and medical
informatics
and he focused his career on the
application
of statistical theory to problems
relevant to laboratory medicine
dr parvin has been an active member of
the clinical and laboratory standards
institute and chaired the document
development committee that produced the
recently published fourth edition
of c24 statistical qc for quantitative
measurement procedures
principles and definitions for a
complete biography
on dr parvin please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen dr parvin
welcome sir
you may now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction and
hello to everybody
and thank you thanks to all of you for
participating in this
webinar and thank you especially for
your interest in laboratory quality
control
subject near and dear to my heart uh so
today today i'll be talking about best
practices in quality control and i'll
offer
10 simple recommendations that hopefully
will help you
to further your efforts to minimize
patient risk in your laboratory
these are some of the learning
objectives that i'm hoping will be
accomplished during this presentation
hopefully after this presentation you'll
be able to better identify factors in qc
error that contribute to
increased patient risk you'll be able to
describe
ways in which quality risk management
has contributed to an
added set of values that the laboratory
should be aware of
and hopefully of the 10 recommendations
i give you'll have at least five of them
that are practices that you could maybe
apply in your laboratory that you're not
currently doing
so i would argue that one of the main
goals in laboratory medicine
is to improve patient health by
providing laboratory test results
that support good medical decisions
in order to accomplish this in the
laboratory we need to provide
accurate test results that enhance
patient care
and minimize patient risk
laboratory quality control is in the
business of trying to minimize
patient risk due to out of control air
conditions or test system failures
so the topics that we'll be discussing
today with regard to laboratory quality
control will be focused really on
minimizing
patient risk of harm
so what do we mean by patient risk
well in statistics which is what i'm
formally trained in
risk is defined as the probability of an
unwanted event
so we talk about the risk of dying
the risk of being in an automobile ass
accident the risk of developing cancer
so this is a probability but it's a
probability of an event that we don't
want to occur
however in risk management
especially additionally in risk
management guidelines that
are devoted to laboratory medicine
risk is defined as two parts containing
two parts it's the combination of
the probability of occurrence of patient
harm
and in addition to that to the severity
of the patient heart
so if two different events unwanted
events
both have the same probability of
occurrence of patient
harm but in one of the two the severity
of the consequence of the patient is
greater
it will be considered a higher risk
now in risk management guidelines
probability of occurrence of
harm is generally recommended to be
classified into categories and here are
two examples from two different risk
management guidelines
clsi ep 23 and iso 14971
the categories are left in the list in
the last column left column and range
from
frequent to improbable and then the uh
the two other columns indicate risks
for ep 23 the risks are given as rates
in time so once per week for frequent
once in a lifetime in the measuring
system for improbable
for iso one four nine seven one their
examples of
classifications are in terms of fraction
of
patient results reported so frequent is
greater than
one out of a thousand patient results
reported cause probability of harm
or one out of a thousand patients
results in probability less than one in
a million results
leading to patient harm
now severity of harm the other part of
the two-part
definition of risk is described in terms
of the severity of the consequence to
the patient
it's meant to be considered
independently of the probability of harm
so there are two
independent assessments
so you could have a situation where
there's a high severity
or a low probability of occurrence or a
high probability of occurrence
likewise you could have a low severity
of harm
for a measurement procedure that has a
high probability or a low probability of
occurrence
now severity of harm is going to depend
upon the analyte
and how that analyte is used in caring
for patients in the particular political
settings
supported by your laboratory
uh both um cls iep 23 and iso
recommend that severity of harm also be
classified into categories
and actually both documents give the
same examples for
the categories and their definitions so
i'm showing it for ep 23 here so
the categories range from negligible
inconvenience or temporary discomfort
all the way up to catastrophic which
means patient death and by station
now once an assessment has been made for
the probability of occurrence of harm
and the severity of that harm for a
particular analyte
and a particular measurement procedure
then the recommendation is to define
and use a risk acceptability matrix
to determine if the risk is acceptable
this is an example of a risk
acceptability matrix that appeared
in the clsi ep 23 guideline
you can see that as the severity of harm
increases the probability of harm that's
considered
accessible acceptable decreases
so for instance if the severity of harm
is considered
minor then as long as the probability of
harm is no greater than occasional it's
considered
acceptable but if the severity of harm
is deemed critical then the probability
of harm
needs to be no greater than remote in
order to be
acceptable so the general idea is the
more severe the consequences to the
patient
the lower the probability of occurrence
of harm has to be
in order for the patient risk to be
accepted
now returning to the concept of the
probability of patient
harm this shows a very nice
model that is described in cls iep 23
that gives an example of the sequence of
events that start with the initiating
cause of somatic control condition
and ultimately lead to patient harm so
the idea here is you have an initiating
cause of a testing process failure that
produces an out of control condition
depending upon the magnitude of that
part of control condition
an increase in the number of incorrect
results are generated
there will be an increase in the
frequency or rate of
incorrect results being generated and
then depending upon the quality control
practices in the laboratory before that
out-of-control condition is detected
some number of those incorrect results
will be reported incorrect results that
are reported by the laboratory create a
hazardous situation for the patient
that is there's an increased likelihood
of patient harm it doesn't necessarily
mean that patient harm will occur but
there is an increased chance of it
now whether or not an increased result
whether or not an
incorrect result that's reported leads
to patient harm
will depend upon how likely it is that
that incorrect result
leads to some kind of misdiagnosis some
kind of incorrect decision that causes
a or leads to a inappropriate
action that then causes patient harm
by definition in my opinion any
inappropriate action that occurs by
definition
means patient harm because it was
something that wouldn't have occurred
if the correct result had been reported
it doesn't say anything about the
severity of the harm it just means that
some
unwanted action occurred
now before i go further into detail on
this
model i think it i should take a little
bit of time here and talk about what do
we
mean by an incorrect result this says an
incorrect result is
generated what do we mean by an
incorrect patient result
well one of the uh
opportunities i had in the recent past
was it shared the document development
committee that
produced the fourth edition of the clsi
document on quality control practices
for quantitative measurement procedures
which is clsi c24
and this is the definition that's given
for an erroneous result in the cls ic24
document i'll just read it it says a
patient result that
fails its quality requirement which is
very similar to the iso
terminology for an incorrect result then
note one the quality requirement is
usually expressed in terms of an
allowable total error requirement
denoted tea
if the measurement error in a patient's
result exceeds the tea requirement the
result
is erroneous and then no two
may also be referred to as an incorrect
result
or an unacceptable result so in the cls
iep 23
document the the model of the sequence
event
events referred to it as an incorrect
result but
the clsi committee decided they liked
the term erroneous results so
the erroneous result incorrect result or
unacceptable result
all mean the same thing but i'll
probably be
most likely using the term erroneous
result
throughout this talk but it means the
same thing as that incorrect result
in the model that i showed
so just to give a little uh um cartoon
uh
to maybe make it clearer what an
erroneous result means
this is showing this curve is showing a
distribution of measurement errors for
some particular measurement procedure
the allowable total error specifications
are
designated here so that
any result that's outside those
allowable total error limits is
considered erroneous any result with
measurement error that's within those
allowable total error
limits is considered useful fit for its
intended use so that's the way we define
an erroneous result
it's a result that has measurement error
in it
that exceeds the allowable total error
requirement and we can compute it if we
know
the distribution measurement errors for
a particular method
so now returning to this model of the
probability of harm
starting from an initiating cause i
wanted to spend a little bit of time
going through each of these steps in a
little more detail and talk about what
how we can think about these different
steps in the process
so we have to begin with a proc
the process the measurement procedure
when it's in control
when there is no uh testing process
failure that has occurred
so the in control probability of
producing erroneous results
really reflects it depends upon
the allowable total error specification
for the analyte
and the inherent uh bias and
imprecision in the measurement procedure
the three things that really define
a sigma value so the in control
probability of producing rooney's
results really reflects
the sigma value for the measurement
procedure the in-control
process capability how likely is it to
produce an erroneous
result when your measurement procedure
is working as it should
now when the frequency with which
testing process failures occur producing
out of control conditions
really reflects the reliability of your
measurement procedure
how often do out of control conditions
occur
clearly the more frequently out of
control conditions occur
the more potential incorrect results
that are generated that could lead
ultimately to patient harm so knowing
the reliability of your measurement
procedure
is important
when for any given out of control
condition that has occurred
the number or rate at which inc in
erroneous results will be to produce is
going to depend upon the magnitude of
that out of control condition
the larger the out of control condition
the more likely it is that erroneous
results will be
generated that potentially can cause
patient harm
so we have to be able to can be prepared
for
any possible magnitude of out of control
condition that might occur
now when an audit control condition is
has occurred
an incorrect results are being generated
how many of those incorrect results get
reported from the library
laboratory will depend upon how
effective the laboratories quality
control practices
are detecting detecting that out of
control condition
as soon as possible the poorer the
ability of the laboratory to detect an
out of control condition
the more incorrect results will be
reported
creating hazardous situations for
patients
that could potentially lead to patient
harm
and then when incorrect results are
reported
how likely it is that an erroneous
result
leads to inappropriate decision
or an inappropriate action
will determine how many of those
incorrect results
lead to patient harm so some knowledge
of
the likelihood that erroneous results
lead to inappropriate decisions or
actions
and
well the knowledge of that is important
in terms of determining how many
uh erroneous results might be the
patient
so now i've kind of gone through in a
little more detail
all the steps in this process
now clearly where the laboratory and
laboratory qc
plays its biggest role is in this
section of that sequence
process inc out of control conditions
occur
how how able are we to detect those out
of control conditions and minimize the
number of incorrect results that are
reported
so that's where really where we tend to
have traditionally focused on our
quality control strategies in
detecting out of control conditions as
soon as possible
however when we're considering the
impact
of our qc practices on the probability
or the risk of patient harm
we also have to be aware of these
aspects of that sequence of events too
in order to assure that the amount of
quality control
effort that we're providing in the
laboratory
minimizes the risk to patients
uh during these stages to an adequate
degree because based on these stages
also
okay so with that brief introduction of
how we relate what we do in the
laboratory in quality control
to this model of the probability of or
the occurrence of patient harm based on
the uh initiation of an out of control
condition
i now want to offer 10 qc
recommendations that
will help minimize patient
risk all of these recommendations are
widely applicable to a wide variety of
laboratory situations their
implementation is
is straightforward doesn't require
advanced
math to either understand them or to
implement them
and they should all to one degree or
another
help reduce patient risk
so recommendation number one always end
patient testing with a qc evaluation
so what do i mean by this so here's a
cartoon that i'm showing of a continuous
testing
process the solid circles are
representing
qcs that are being tested periodically
if the
circles are green that means that the qc
rule was accepted and if they're red it
means it's rejected
the open circles are patient results
that are being tested between the qc
events
now as this continuous process is going
along there is a point in time
in time where an event occurs
uh that causes the laboratory
to take pause or to be potentially
concerned that this event
might have an impact on the state of the
of the of the process that uh it could
adversely impact the
measurement procedure these are referred
to as critical control points and
they're
typically things like calibration
preventive maintenance maybe it's just
the end of the day of testing
you're going to shut down and then start
up in the next day but this is an
event that causes one pause
you want to make sure that this event
hasn't adversely affected your
measurement procedure
now if that event occurs
and we don't do any qc testing just
before that event
then all of the patient results that
have been
reported since the last accepted qc
event we don't really know what the
status of those
are we can't be assured of whether or
not
some out of control conditions some
testing process failure has occurred
between the last except accused event
and this critical control point
now if we were to test qcs
just before that critical control point
and we got a qc rejection
then we would be concerned about all of
those patient results that had been
reported
back to the last accepted qc event and
we would probably want to investigate
them
hopefully if we tested qcs just before
that critical control point and we got a
qc acceptance
then that would reassure us that
all of those patient results back to the
last except the qc
were acceptable uh that we had minimized
or mitigated the risk to the patient
now clearly it's almost always
recommended that after that critical
control point the first thing that you
do is to test qcs because
our concern was that that critical
control point
might have the potential to adversely
affect our measurement procedure
and if we test qcs and we get a
rejection then that
would tell us that indeed that's the
case and we would have to do some
troubleshooting until we could test qcs
and we got qc acceptance and then we
would continue on
with our testing process
now almost everybody every lab would
test cues
c's after a critical control point um
i'm not sure how many labs test them
before every critical control point but
i will point out that in the
current edition the fourth edition of
the cls ic24 document
it actually is stated in there that
laboratory
should test qcs both before
and after critical control points
recommendation number two try to make
the time
between qc evaluations no longer than
the time needed to correct results
before they're acted on
so what do i mean by this so iso 15189
states that when qc detects an out of
control condition
laboratory should inspect and correct
adversely affected patient results
already released
so in this particular cartoon uh once we
get accuracy rule rejection all of those
patient results with question marks
should be inspected and corrected
if they were adversely affected
if it turns out the length of time
between that last accepted qc event
and the qc event that gives a rule
rejection is so
great that most of the patient results
that have been reported between those
two events
have already been acted upon then you
haven't mitigated the risk to the
patient
it's not good enough just to detect the
out of control condition
you have to be able to detect the out of
control condition
and be able to go back and identify and
correct
adversely affected patient results
before they're acted upon
now in some cases uh because of the way
the laboratory
laboratory testing is performed and
results are acted upon
the ability to keep that interval short
enough so that you cannot
so that you can identify and correct any
result before it's acted upon is
unrealistic but it's important for the
laboratory to be aware
of the typical situation and how often
and how long it takes for
results to be acted upon and try to make
sure that the interval between qc events
especially
for uh situations where the consequences
to the patient of an erroneous result
could be severe
that that interval of time is not too
great
recommendation number three know the
number of patient results between qc
evaluations
so recommendation number two was really
related to
trying to recover from a nautical
control condition
that has been detected and that recovery
really depends upon
time this recommendation is really uh
patient risk related detecting and out
of control condition
and it depends on the number of results
between qc evaluations
so this cartoon again is showing two
different
laboratories they're both testing qcs
every 24 hours the diamonds are the qc
events
green meaning except red meaning reject
the vertical lines are the patient
results
and the little red asterisks are patient
results that are incorrect or erroneous
so in both of these cases both of these
labs
they're doing testing once every 24
hours
and they have an out of control
condition of the same magnitude that
occurs at the exact same time
but the top lab does many fewer tests in
a 24-hour period
than the lower lab so as you can see
even though they both detected it at the
next scheduled qc event
the lower lab has many many more
patient results that were erroneous than
the upper lab
even though they're testing at the same
rate in terms of time
so really from the laboratory's
perspective patient risk
is dependent upon the number of patients
evaluated between qc evaluations not the
length of time
so it's important for you to have a
sense for each of your analytes
the average number of course the number
of patients tested between any
uh two qc events is going to vary from a
day to day and
within day but you need to have a sense
for the average number of qc events
or an average number of patients that
are tested between
qc events for your analytes
recommendation number four estimate the
magnitude of an out of control condition
before correcting
it so the first three recommendations
were really about trying to
mitigate or minimize patient risk this
recommendation is
really more about trying to minimize
cost of rework or cost of poor quality
this is the only one that's really
not so much focused on patient risk it's
focused on
uh minimizing cost of rework or poor
quality
so when a qc detects an out of control
condition
the qc results that produce that out of
control
uh event have very little information
about the magnitude of the
characteristic of that out of control
condition
so when you get a qc rule rejection
if before you detect and correct the
problem
if you do try to do a better job of
estimating the magnitude of that out of
control condition
it can provide you some assistance in
doing a better job
of recovering from that auto concoction
so the
again at the bottom i give an example of
two different
out of control conditions in the upper
cartoon the out of control condition is
fairly
small it's small enough so that it took
a couple of qc events for us to detect
it
but relatively few of the patient
results are erroneous
in the lower example the out of control
condition is
quite large large enough so that we
detect it at the next
scheduled qc event but a large
fraction of the patient results are
erroneous
now when we get that qc rule rejection
we really don't have very much
information at all to
distinguish between these two cases but
if before we corrected the out of
control conditions
if we were to try to get a better
estimate a simple way of doing that
would be just to run
additional replicates of each of your
qcs maybe say three or four
additional recommend replicates and then
when you take the average
of those four or five replicates now
for each level of control you have a
much more precise
estimate of the magnitude of the out of
control condition that can kind of
produce for you a
error profile across the concentration
range
in that situation you'd be able to
determine
that that lower situation was a much
larger error
meaning it's much more likely that quite
a few of your results
back to the last except the qc event
were erroneous
and the way you'd go about and the
effort that you make in terms of
identifying and correcting those
might be different than it would be for
the upper example
uh where it looks like the the number or
the fraction of
results that are erroneous is much much
lower
recommendation number five if you're
using a one
two sqc rule and you get a rule failure
repeat it but just once
so what do i mean by a repeat one to sqc
rule let's assume we have two levels of
qc
the way that this rule will be applied
is you measure both qc's
if both are within plus or minus 2s then
you accept
if both are outside plus or minus 2s
then you reject
otherwise repeat both qcs
if both repeated values are within plus
or minus 2s then accept
otherwise reject okay
now note this is not a repeat repeat
repeat got lucky
qc practice there's been a lot written
about
laboratories that just continue to
repeat their qc until they get them
until they get
qcs that are in that's not what is what
is being proposed here
this is a qc rule
that has the possibility of running a
second set of qcs
depending upon the results obtained in
the first set
now in my visits around laboratories
around the world over the last
decade or more and talking labs about
what qc
rules they use a lot of labs say that
they use a 1 2 s rule
but then when you talk to them about it
a little bit get them to describe a
little more
detail exactly what it is you'll do they
do
you'll discover that really what they're
doing is a repeat one to us so they'll
do a 1 2 s rule
and if they uh get something out they'll
repeat it
and if it's in then they'll keep going
if it's out again then they'll reject
so it i came away from that thinking you
know there are probably a lot of labs
that are doing this repeat one twist
rule but there's really been no
formal evaluation of what the
characteristics what the abilities of
that kind of a rule are so a number of
years ago i did a study
and published a paper in the journal
clinical chemistry
and it turns out that a repeat one to us
rule is a very powerful rule
this is a figure that is a modification
of a figure that appears in the clinton
chem
article this is uh showing power
functions so the
horizontal axis here is showing the
magnitude of an out of control condition
in multiples of standard deviation so
the left
intercept is zero so that's no water
control condition you're in control
and as you move to the right it's
increasing magnitudes of out of control
errors in shift and then the vertical
axis is the probability of a rule
rejection and each curve represents a qc
rule
the solid red curve is a 1 2s rule the
solid green curve
is a 1 3s rule you can see that the one
to s rule is very very powerful but the
problem with the one 2s rule with two
qc's is its false rejection rate
where it intersects the vertical axis is
at about 0.9
about nine percent so it has a very high
unacceptably high false rejection rate
the uh
the green curve the 1 3s has a nice low
false rejection rate but its power is
not very very
good i've shown two uh common
multi rules is the dash curves
the dashed uh black curve
is a one three s two two s r four 4s
multirule
and the pink curve is a 1 3s 22s
r4s41s multi rule that's effectively the
westgard multi rule without the 10x
bar and the 10x bar in many circles now
is argued that
people shouldn't use that rule so that's
effectively the westcott multi-rule
the solid blue curve is the repeat one
two s
qc rule and you can see that the repeat
one to s rule
is much more powerful than either of the
multi rules
certainly much more powerful than one 3s
rule
not as powerful as the uh
the one to s rule for for small out of
control conditions but it has a much
more
acceptable false rejection to fall for
injection rates about one percent
for the rpp12
recommendation number six divide
analytes into high and low
sigma metric groups so the sigma metric
which i've alluded to earlier is defined
as the allowable total error
specification
for your analyte minus any inherent bias
in your measurement procedure divided by
the
in control and precision or sd of your
measurement procedure
so effectively it's the number of
process
sds that fit within the allowable total
error specification
it's really measuring the in control
capability
of your measurement procedure now high
sigma metric processes
are easy to see low sigma metric
processes
are harder to qc and i'll try to justify
that that those last two points uh with
uh some cartoons
so this is showing the distribution of
measurement error
for a particular measurement procedure
that has
that is a three sigma process so you'll
notice that the allowable total error
limits are at plus or minus three
sigma and we're assuming that this
particular measurement procedure is
unbiased so it's centered on zero
when this process is operating in its in
control state
there is about a three and a thousand
chance
of producing uh results that have
measurement error that exceed the
allowable total error
so about a 300 000 chance of producing
erroneous results
however if a antiotic control condition
occurred that produced a 2
sd shift in the process
while this is the state of your
measurement
process in its out of control condition
there is greater than a 15 chance
that your results will have uh
an unacceptable amount of measurement
here they'll be erroneous
so when a 2sd shift in a process
occurs for us three sigma metric
measurement procedure you better be able
to detect that out of control condition
very quickly because while it's
undetected
about one out of seven of your patient
results
will be erroneous now conversely let's
look at a six sigma process so now the
only difference here is that
the total error limits are at plus or
minus six
rather than plus or minus three
in this situation when you're in control
there's about a
two and a billion chance of exceeding
allowable total error
requirements so for a six sigma process
when you're in control
you should never expect to see results
that have measurement here that exceed
your quality requirement
and if a two sd shift
occurred in this process a six sigma
process
there is still less than a one in ten
thousand chance
of exceeding the allowable total error
requirement
so it's not nearly as critical to detect
a two standard deviation
shift in the six sigma process
as it is in a free signal process
so for high sigma metric processes
you can take advantage of that process
capability to maybe reduce the false
rejection rate
widen your limits for your qc rules and
reduce the false rejection rates because
false rejections
have costs associated with them you
might reduce the frequency of qc testing
but remember you can only do this if
your recovery requirements permit it
that's that recommendation number two
you can't go
so long between qc tests that when you
do detect
an issue you can't recover from it in a
timely enough
fashion to prevent
actions on erroneous results before
they're corrected
or you could strengthen your quality
claim that is specify a smaller label
tool layer
you can say that you're able to uh
produce results that emit a
a more stringent quality requirement for
for your customers for low sigma metric
processes
seek ways to reduce bias and precision
those are the two things
that make for a low sigma metric if you
can't
do that use more powerful qc rules or
increase your
increase your qc frequency and if none
of that works then maybe you have to
reassess whether or not your quality
specification is realistic maybe you
have to widen
your uh quality specification
recommendation number seven
don't rely solely on sigma values to
determine your acoustic speed
strategy so six was just saying use your
qc
your sigma values to kind of determine
how you do qc
this recommendation is saying that's
important but don't rely
solely on sigma values to determine your
qc strategy
the reason for this recommendation is
that there have recently been
publications that have appeared
that provide tables such as this it's
referred to as a sigma metric
based qc strategy design and
the table implies that the number of qcs
that you test the qc rule that you use
and the frequency of
qc testing can all be based simply on
the sigma metric
so for instance if your sigma value is
greater than or equal to 6
you run two qc she's a 1 3s rule and you
can test every thousand patient
specimens
however if your q if your sigma value is
between
four and five then maybe you should use
four qc's
use a multi and only just every 200
qc patient samples
now the q s the sigma metric
is important for determining how able
you are to detect
shifts of a certain magnitude but
remember
there are other aspects of that sequence
of events not just
within the lab but outside the lab and
there are important issues that we have
to consider
there in order to determine how good our
qc needs to be
so my last three recommendations are all
going to kind of be based on
this point that for the same sigma
metric depending upon other issues maybe
different
amounts of qc are required oh
so i i'm sorry so um um
in response to tables like that um uh
uh i and a colleague at bio-rad
wrote a paper mlo in 2018
making this point don't rely solely on
signal values to determine qc frequency
and goes over some of these other issues
that i'll
refer to in my last three
recommendations
so recommendation eight devote more qc
effort to
unreliable measurement procedures so
remember in this sequence of events
the reliability of our measurement
procedure determines how
frequently out of control conditions
occur each out of control condition has
the
ability of producing incorrect results
that are reported
so we need to provide
more effort at detecting and and
correcting out of control conditions for
methods that are unreliable or another
way of saying this
two different measurement procedures
that have the same exact
sigma value but one method is much less
reliable than the other
the less reliable method we need to
devote more effort in our qc
in order to keep the patient the risk of
patient harm
at an acceptable level
recommendation number nine the more qc
effort to analyze
with a high probability that erroneous
results lead to patient harm
so again how likely it is that incorrect
results that we report
lead to patient harm will depend upon
the information content
in those results and how likely it is
that an erroneous result will be enough
to cause an inappropriate decision or
action that leads to patient harm
so for those situations that have a high
probability that ronnie's results will
lead to inappropriate assistance or
actions
we need to devote more qc effort so that
we can minimize the number of those
erroneous results reported or another
way of saying it
two different measurement procedures
that have the exact same
sigma value but in one case it's an
analyte where the likelihood that an
erroneous reported result leads to
inappropriate decisions or actions than
the other
for that one we need to devote more
effort to our qc even though they have
the same
signal value and then lastly
more qc effort to analytes with high
expected severity of patient harm
from an erroneous result remember our
risk acceptability matrix
made the point that the higher the
severity of harm
the lower the probability of harm must
be in order to be acceptable
so for two different
measurement procedures that have the
exact same
sigma value if one of them is for an
analyte
where the kinds of patient care
situations involved with that analyte
and the decisions and actions taken
are such that if an inappropriate action
occurs it has
severe consequences then we need to
devote
more qc effort in that situation
than we do for one that where this
consequences are
not severe
so in summary a laboratory's tolerance
for reporting erroneous
patient results should depend on the
likelihood that erroneous results lead
to harm and the severity of that harm
those are the two things
that define patient risk the
laboratory's impact on patient risk
depends upon
the in-control performance of the lab's
measurement procedure
its sigma value it depends upon the
reliability of the lab's measurement
procedure
and it depends upon the lab's qc
strategy
i've not i've described based upon this
patient risk model a number of simple qc
practices that can help minimize
patient risk that are easily implemented
don't require advanced math or computer
software
and so with that i thank you for your
kind attention
and i that completes my presentation
thank you so much dr parvin for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question that you'd like
to ask please do so
now so you just click on the ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen let's get started
so dr parvin our first question is as
you know
most lab tests have hundreds of
different tests
it would take a major effort to do risk
assets assessments on all our tests
is that feasible or are labs just doing
this for some tests
uh yeah that's a very important point
god typically what
uh what i recommend or what we recommend
is
for a laboratory to start with a handful
of tests that
for whatever reason they feel are
challenging or problematic
they might be challenged or problematic
because they're it's a low sigma value
it's a test that tends to be unreliable
maybe it's an analyte that
when they do make mistakes the potential
consequences to the patient are quite
severe
but start with a handful that you're
interested in trying to improve
and go through this process this this
thought exercise and this process
with those and then if you find that it
was a good experience that it had value
then um when you're done with it you
expect that you'd be
eager to uh tackle the next handful and
just kind of march through it that way
then
uh um and over time you can uh
uh um challenge take uh those all of
those
situations that are uh that you find
challenging
it might also be on the converse side
there might be
situations where there are certain uh
measurement procedures that just seem to
be rock solid you
you feel like man these things are just
they never cause me any problem and you
want to look at those
maybe and go through this kind of
process to consider whether or not
you could back off some of the effort
that you're making on qc so that you
have that additional
amount of qc resource that you can
provide for the more
problematic situations
thank you um so our next question
you showed us 10 recommendations to
implement
from your experience which would be your
first two practices
to start with
and the two uh okay uh well first of all
my for my you know i haven't been in a
laboratory in in
over a decade uh so it's going to
certainly depend upon each laboratory
but
a couple that come to mind that are
fairly
easy to implement straightforward
for any laboratory and that are kind of
backed by some recommendations now would
be
this idea of testing
qcs not only after but also before
any critical control points that you've
identified in your laboratory this again
is
one of the recommendations in the c24
document now
and that's something that any lab can do
if they aren't currently doing it
and it's certainly certainly in those
situations too where it might be a
fairly unreliable measurement procedure
so you're
expecting that this procedure can go out
of control
more frequently than others then it's
probably really important to make sure
that you're
mitigating the risk to those patients
that have
been reported since elastics at the qc
event
but prior to the critical control point
so that would be one
uh the other one uh would be the uh
vp12s rule i'd say that
for laboratories uh in those situations
where they have some
challenging assays because they have low
sigma values
that a repeat 1 2s rule is a very
straightforward way of improving the
power
depending unless you're doing something
esoteric now if you're already running
ewma rules or qsum rules and if you
don't know what that is then you're not
running them
but if you're running just the typical
multi-rule kinds of things
the repeat one 2s rule really is going
to give you more power
and is easy to implement the advantage
of the repeat one twist two
will do is that typically uh
when a a real error is detected it's
because you've done
a repeat so one of the side benefits
from that is when you've now detected
that other control condition you have
twice as many qc results
at your disposal to to help estimate the
magnitude of that out of control
condition for recovery purposes
so dr parvin our next question
by dividing my analytes into high and
low sigma tests
how would the lab deal with different qc
frequencies by analytes and number of
patients
that's a great question and that's one
that uh i've done a lot of uh i
published a lot of papers on
determining an appropriate qc frequency
and one of the challenges when you
uh go through that exercise is that you
might have a particular control material
that has
20 different analytes that are being
measured and you've
gone through this exercise and come up
with 20 different appropriate
frequencies of testing and how do you do
that
meaningfully well the the easy answer is
if you have some of the uh of the uh
instrument technology that's becoming
more more popular now
like the vistas which allow you to uh
have onboard qc and schedule
your qc uh on an analyte by analog basis
then it takes care of itself
but for those situations where really
the laboratory has to schedule
their qcs either on the clock
at a particular time of the day or maybe
by
number of patients between qc events
then the recommendation that i usually
make
is you divide your um your measurement
procedures into high and low sigma
groups
and then you define two different qc
schedules
one that's in a multiple an exact
multiple of the other so if you're doing
it in time it might be you have an
eight-hour schedule and a four-hour
schedule
if you're doing a number of patient
samples it might be that you are
test patients every every 200 patients
and every 100 patients
and then for those measurement
procedures that have a low
sigma you test those at the high
frequency
schedule but those that are high sigma
you just
test those every other at the low
frequency
that seems to work you can get more
sophisticated you can have three
different schedules uh
that all kind of depends on your lab and
how easy it will be to manage those
kinds of things
awesome thank you and your second
recommendation
said to set qc no longer than it takes
to correct
results before they are acted on what is
your recommendation
when the results are auto verified and
released and the next qc
may not be until the next shift or day
yeah yeah and so i alluded that a little
to that a little when i was uh talking
about it but
um certainly uh there are a lot of
of uh analytes that are being ordered
and reported
where the turnaround time is critical i
mean they're being auto verified and
they're being reported
because uh a healthcare provider wants
that result
quickly uh so if you you know if you
think the result's going to be acted
upon
within an hour it might not be
practical to be testing qcs every hour
because it's just not not
feasible but i think the important point
here is that in those situations
where you know that if an
uh an action is taken based on an
erroneous result
that the consequences to the patient can
be significant
um in those cases you have to make sure
that
that you have ways of being
able to stop those actions from
occurring
once an auto control condition has been
detected before they harm the patient
if you're dealing with situations where
the severity of harm
is nothing more than the order a repeat
of the test
and maybe that's not such a big deal but
the consequences are that they're going
to be taken to surgery
uh if it's an erroneous result and they
wouldn't have been if they weren't
you want to make sure that you don't
don't allow those things to happen
and even though your signal value might
tell you that you could test qcs once a
day
you might have to decide that no you
know what we got to test qcs
three times a day or six times a day
because we can't afford uh even if we
can detect that out of control condition
the first time we
uh test for it we can't afford the
amount of time that's gone on that we've
been reporting results that could have
been acted upon
causing severe consequences to a patient
okay and our next question
the third recommendation is to know
number of patients between
qc evaluations um what are your thoughts
for labs
whose patient volumes vary from day to
day
oh yeah yeah absolutely um and and they
will they're not only
very day to day but depending on your
laboratory they very likely vary within
day you know
much much more volume in the middle of
the day than in the middle of the night
uh and weekends different than weekdays
etc
uh but the real key here is just um
on average knowing which are your
analytes
that um you do a lot of and which ones
aren't
for example again most patient orders
that are sent to the lab there are
multiple analytes that are being ordered
on a particular specimen
and you might find that in a in an eight
hour shift you're testing qcs every
eight hours in an eight hour shift
you've got
500 patient samples and of those 500
patient samples
400 400 of them have had electrolytes
ordered
but only three of them have had calciums
ordered or some other
rarely ordered tests and it's so it's
important to know
um what kind of volume of
analyte orders there are uh in the
intervals of time that or in the
intervals of number of patients that
you're
processing uh between qc events so that
you can because really as i've already
said
the um the uh the risk from the
laboratory's perspective has to do with
the number of
patients tested between qc events not
the time
time is important for recovery but
patients is report
is important for the detection part so
it's just i think it's
it's just of value for a laboratory to
have an
idea of what their testing volume is and
it can be on an average you know
we do three to five of these uh uh
in a shift or in a day and we do 400 of
these in the shift or in the day
or in a in a ticket in the interval
between
typical qc events
great and we have time for just one more
question
dr parvin on your last slide you
indicate the laboratory's tolerance for
reporting
erroneous patience results should depend
on the likelihood
that erroneous patient results lead to
harm and severity of patient harm
the tolerance also depends on the
context and specific situation
for the testing for example an emergency
room
diagnosis or disease monitoring have you
how have you seen labs do this yeah
and this this is a really good question
an important point that
that i'll editorialize on a little bit
um
traditionally in the laboratory
the way that we've dealt with quality
control is
we've effectively treated our
instruments in the lab
as if they were our patient you know
what we're trying to do is keep
healthy instruments healthy patients a
healthy instrument or health is
an instrument that's operating and it's
in control state
a sick instrument is an instrument
that's operating in an out of control
state and what we've
done is thought about how to design qc
strategies so that when our
patient the instrument becomes sick we
can identify that
and make the patient well again as soon
as possible
well some of the things that i'm talking
about as we move
from not focusing on the instrument in
the lab but focusing on the patient
uh it brings into play
a number of issues a number of aspects
that aren't just related to the
instrument things like the severity
department to the patient
how the results are used unfortunately
or fortunately depending upon you how
you
who how you look at it and who you talk
to what that require what that means is
a
lot of the information a lot of the
guidance and advice that might be
required for designing a good qc
strategy to minimize patient risk
requires some knowledge that maybe your
typical quality control
manager in the laboratory doesn't feel
comfortable with it really requires
knowledge that's maybe at the level of
your laboratory director who's an md or
phd
or your physician and nurse colleagues
are actually the ones that make use of
the results for taking care of patients
so when i've talked to laboratories
about some of these issues
they oftentimes
show concern because they don't know how
to
be making decisions or talking about
things like severity of harm and the
patient
the patient care scenarios that might be
typical for this particular
analyte for the patient populations that
they're serving
uh and they they feel uncomfortable
about it what i say to them is well you
need to
rely upon your medical director or your
physician colleagues to kind of help you
with that
when i talk to medical directors they
are excited about this
they because this is their area of
expertise this is where they feel that
they can really provide
some added value in helping the
laboratory
provide a quality service to the uh the
care providers the patient care
providers
uh so when i talk to physicians they
they're all excited about these ideas
when i talk to a
med tech that's dealing with quality
control sometimes they look like
a deer in the headlights so it does
require
um bringing in expertise from outside
the lab
that's more involved in how these
results are used in patient care
and as it was pointed out in the
question for an in particular analyte
there are a number of different patient
care scenarios some that could
result in really ugly things happening
and others that aren't
and it's the it's the the medical
director the physician
uh client that really has to give some
guidance in terms of
these are the most typical situations
with
which we find ourselves and these are
the kinds of consequences in terms of
the severity of harm and these are the
kinds of likelihoods
that if you gave us a bad result we
would do something we shouldn't do or
fail to do something that we should do
so that's a very good point and
the good news bad news is it's bringing
health care providers are
people with medical knowledge into the
picture which is
good if we're trying to minimize patient
risk
but it does uh make more uh challenges
in the laboratory in terms of doing
these things
thank you again dr pervin for your time
today and your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience as well for joining us today
and for their interesting questions they
have submitted
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed
by the speaker and posted in the event
resources
next week this webcast will now be
available on demand
if you found this informative and
helpful please share with your
colleagues
bio rad will be hosting a new qc related
webinar
every month this year please check back
regularly
for new topics and take time to explore
our posters and booths in the virtual
conference
until next time stay safe goodbye